a silly but very important question to
start here for both of you how do you
take your eggs
eggs is that what he
said free boiled eggs this morning it
was nice fre boiled eggs yeah machine
yeah boiled hard boiled okay I respect
that choice what about you Jacob runny
like barries in the movie yeah raw Paul
is just telling me about an ALT version
of that where there was actual actually
like a Bloody Chicken in the middle of
it there was something vile on that
plate peaches and yogurt like it Ain no
it was no cooland Luke with the eggs
yeah great reference you know what I
mean it was
like squeeze in uh a spoiler-free
question before I really start to dig
into some of the details here can you
each tell me something that you
appreciate about the other as a scene
partner maybe even something that helped
you reach something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to without him Jacob I'll let you
take that one first Barry is um like
pure
electricity when he when he acts yeah
and you uh you really don't know sort of
what's going to happen in a scene so you
have to be on your toes and I really
appreciated that those little Sparks and
Jabs thank you nice way to describe it
thank you
yeah uh go on come on put the pressure
on no with Jacob
um you know he matches your energy uh
you know he let you take the lead and
and it comes back and you know it's not
the same same thing over and over again
which which I admire because then it
allows me to you know React to what I'm
I'm seeing and what what's in front of
me um and it's the sign of a really
really good actor I'll raise the the
spoiler warning for our viewers here in
case they haven't seen the movie to
build on that so given he gives you
something different every single take is
there a particular scene in the movie
that evolved the most from take one to
your very last take of that scene yeah
I'd say the scene where we come back
from from my parents house yeah the car
yeah you know that whole sequence was uh
yeah because I could tell he was really
frustrated you was I don't know we yeah
it was just we were laid into the shoot
and we were in this car being dragged
around the countryside and you couldn't
hear us so we had to yell our lines CU
we in this kind of roof off Land Rover
and we were just frustrated as um as
actors because our trailers weren't
there or you know we had no get my
coffee bought to me or anything like
that so I was just absolutely losing my
marbles and um but no there was there
was definitely but that whole sequence
that whole sequence kind
of uh evolved from what it was in the
script for sure I'm really happy with it
yeah same two of us kind of frustrating
and yeah it became very erratic in the
final thing which I think really works
all right to get at a couple other
specific moments here Barry I'll throw
this one your way of all of the scenes
in the movie minus maybe the the last
dance scene in which one do you think
that Oliver shows his true colors the
most where he's acting the least and we
get the best view of who he is to his
core I mean that would be meeting the
parents wouldn't it his parents uh we
see a young boy I think even in you know
I want to do something with the
physicality in that as well I wanted to
really drop my shoulders and
really kind of mope and dropped the head
uh because we've seen he no way out of
this uh you know and it was awkward and
it was you know I really felt awkward I
really felt like you know it's um I
think that's the the true Oliver and we
see him beg almost you know beg to stay
a part of his life andh you know he
doesn't want to lose this this
relationship so yeah that's that's one
of the the moments yeah shared
awkwardness I feel I feel the weight of
it while watching it for sure when I was
talking to Emerald she kept stressing
that you know this movie is mostly about
love but filled with a whole bunch of
characters who don't really know how to
express it in a healthy manner so it was
making me wonder do you think that Felix
truly loved Oliver deep down or is there
always a part of him that does know that
he is just a seasonal toy that will
eventually be cut off I think he loves
everything fully and completely I don't
I don't think he's conscious of um the
kind of Cruelty that's inside him so
true which is like most people you know
I don't I don't think I don't think a
lot of people set out to be cruel and
yet look at where we live feel like that
makes it even more disturbing one of
thing or sad and messy and hopeful I
mean that's like that's that's reaching
for for the
everyone is trying as they might in the
you know as long as you're uh
you're trying it doesn't have
consequences like we see in this movie
that's fine by May speaking of the the
con the consequences here I was
wondering before before Felix passes do
you think he has like any slight moment
of knowing what happened knowing that
his demise was directly caused by Oliver
no I think I think his uh I I think his
blood is just turned to ice I think he's
just terrified of uh of of someone like
that but I don't think he can sort of
see what's coming no all right Barry
I'll uh wrap with a question that I have
a feeling you're getting a lot today I
want to ask about that final dance
because I've heard Emerald say that that
wasn't originally the plan for that
particular scene so what was your
reaction when it just me getting bed was
your original plan and then I I said
keep the camera rolling I'll do
something special here and they followed
me and I took my clothes off can we get
my kid off should I get my kid off that
was the whole thing take my top off take
it all off but uh we all one thing we
all do I don't know if we all do but I
know most of us we all dance around our
house naked I know for a fact we do
right we do we all do and it's like do
you know me I think that's why a lot of
people are relating with it is like yeah
I've done that you know what I mean and
we we we're silly with our moves and
we're like just letting you know our
bodies moveing way super super relatable
you know mean Slaughter an entire family
Ste their home you know what I mean do a
bunch of cocaine and dance naked in
their living room yeah walk through a
munion a gorgeous munion I mean when I
get out of my bed it's like my kitchen's
there and my set room's there so I can't
really dance but you're in a hotel room
yeah oh and with this one quick one here
uh Barry what do you think life is like
for Oliver after the events of the movie
is there any chance he can live happily
ever after or is salt saltburn ruined
for him once there's no one left in it
but him I me he's got nothing to play
with you know what a Fed Up little boy
man whatever man boy man child but he uh
he's got that's it like you know he's I
don't think he has anything to kind of
experiment with you
know he'll go find another family
torture
them
franchise or the attack of Duncan that
too I think Duncan winds up coming back
Duncan killing him and taking salurn I
have to let you guys go you have a lot
to do today I'm going to say huge
congratulations love your I will
continue to watch it over and over there
are many details to thank you
guys